So yesterday we had the first joint event
of the Biden Harris ticket with Kamala Harris.
Of course, Joe joining Joe Biden on the ticket
the day before yesterday.
I covered this event live on.
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook, and I have to
tell you, the event was remarkable in how
unremarkably normal it was.
And when things haven't been normal for a
long time, that actually sort of makes an
impression on you.
And what I mean by that is Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris were able to stay on topic, put together
a simple, coherent narrative about why we
should vote for them rather than Trump Pence.
They spoke in complete sentences, finished
thoughts.
And it sounds like a very low bar because
it is.
But that's what's wild about it.
A whole bunch of stuff is now unusual because
of the last three and a half years of Donald
Trump.
Super interesting, by the way, that the viewership
for this event was many times higher than
the viewership for Trump's press briefing,
which was scheduled at essentially the same
time.
And, you know, there might be some novelty
element.
Biden Harris out on the campaign trail is
a new thing and maybe that's generating interest.
But there was this sense of, hey, this is
kind of normal and we like it.
Let's look at a few clips.
Here is Joe Biden introducing Kamala Harris
and using this terminology of whining, which
is interesting because when Trump first spoke
about Harris on Tuesday during the press briefing,
I said he's just whining about her.
And that's exactly the same language Joe Biden
used yesterday.
You all knew was coming.
You could have set your watches to it.
Donald Trump has already started his attacks,
calling Common a, quote, nasty whining about
how she is, quote, mean to his appointees.
It's no surprise because whining is what Donald
Trump does best.
Better than any president.
American history.
Is anyone surprised Donald Trump has a problem
with a strong woman or strong women across
the board?
Mike Pence does well against Kamala Harris
in a debate.
Trump is also the reason millions of Americans
are now unemployed.
He inherited the longest economic expansion
in history from Barack Obama and Joe Biden.
And then, like everything else he inherited,
he ran it straight into the ground because
of Trump's failures of leadership.
Our economy has taken one of the biggest hits
out of all the major industrialized nations
with an unemployment rate that has tripled
as of today.
This is what happens when we elect a guy who
just isn't up for the job.
And then here is Kamala Harris focusing right
in on Corona virus, which I think is smart.
I mean, when when you look at polling, Corona
virus is one of the top issues on which Trump
is most upside down, where people think he
has failed and corona virus is regularly in
the top two issues for what matters most to
the country right now.
So I believe this is the right way to hit
Donald Trump.
Now, when other countries are following the
science, Trump pushed miracle cures he saw
on Fox News while other countries were flattening
the curve.
He said the virus would just poof, go away.
Quote, like a miracle.
So when other countries open back up for business,
what did we do?
We had to shut down again.
This virus has impacted almost every country,
but there's a reason it has hit America worse
than any other advanced nation.
It's because of Trump's failure to take it
seriously from the start.
So here's my thought.
Even if you don't like Kamala Harris in terms
of her politics, if she is to your right as
she is with me, the energy she's bringing
is much needed.
And it's a noted counterpoint to Trump Pence.
And in fact, it appears that that's exactly
how polls show people reacting.
Harris of the four Trump, Pence, Biden, Harris
Harris is the only one polling with net favor
ability, meaning favorability exceeds people
who view her unfavorably.
And this is an early sign that from a strategic
standpoint, strategic.
This may have been a very good pick.
It all remains to be seen.
Next week, we'll have the DNC.
The next week after that, we will have the
RNC.
Then we will be close to debates.
And so it's going to be meaningless.
This is the election.
We're weeks away.
It's going to be a very busy couple of months
and we're going to be with you for the entire
thing.
And August.
Twenty third will be the 15 year anniversary
of the David Pakman show.
We'll be running a beautiful, possibly illegal
membership special.
And I encourage you to get on our newsletter
at David Pakman dot com.
You'll get an email on the twenty third telling
you how to take advantage of.
This it's just a crazy, crazy membership discount,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.
Today's new members of the day are Jeff Helliwell
and also a viewer who goes by the name Enigmatic
Ecstasy.
There's probably some interesting backstory
there.
Thanks to both of you for supporting the program.
Also big, thank you to Matthew Schlegel, who's
today's longtime sustaining member of the
day.
Matt has been a member for a long time and
little inside story.
Matt actually helped The David Pakman Show
acquire one of our first tri casters, which
was a big part of improving the show very
early on.
So, Matt, today's longtime sustaining member
of the day, joined these great people by grabbing
a membership at join Pacman dot com.
Okay.
We now have the first major election forecast
for Biden versus Trump in November.
And it tells us exactly what I told you last
week, which is that Donald Trump can easily
win this election.
I'm talking about the 538 forecast, which
sort of synthesizes all the polling information
at the national and state level, combines
it with historical data, combines it with
other factors.
It's all analyzed and outcomes, a number that
tells us how likely is it that Trump will
win and how likely is it that Joe Biden will
win.
And these numbers are then up to us to interpret.
In this case, the numbers are that 538 gives
Joe Biden a 71 percent chance of winning.
And it gives Donald Trump a 29 percent chance
of winning.
Now.
Careful.
If you believe this is accurate, it is way
too close to think that anything is remotely
certain in this election, 71 to 29.
In practical terms is 50 50 now.
I want people to really understand the math
of this.
What this means is that if you were to run
100 elections with today's inputs, today's
inputs in seventy one of those hundred elections,
Joe Biden would win.
And in twenty nine of those hundred elections,
Donald Trump would win.
If nothing changes.
Now, of course, if anything changes between
now and November in the direction of Trump,
that 29 percent number goes up.
But forget about that.
Twenty nine percent is really, really high.
I mean, just apply it to your life.
Does anybody get on a plane if there's a 29
percent chance of a problem with the plane's
flight worthiness?
Of course not.
Does anybody go to a dentist and you have
them fix a cavity?
If there is a 29 percent chance they make
a mistake, you would never go to that dentist
more trivially.
I don't take a sip of water if I think there
is a two point nine percent chance the water
is tainted.
Never mind.
Twenty nine percent.
So for all intents and purposes, in terms
of our behavior.
Twenty nine percent is like 50/50.
And if you need any more convincing about
that, when announcing the forecast, Nate Silver
from 538 actually said, coincidentally, these
are the exact same odds as in our final forecast
in 2016, which was Clinton 71 percent chance
to win, Trump 29 percent.
Now, if you want to, do, you know, a little
bit of multiplication.
The odds of Trump winning twice in a row with
29 percent likelihood is about eight percent.
This is like flipping a coin.
If you flip a coin once, the odds of heads
are 50 percent.
If after that first flip, you flip it a second
time.
The odds of heads on that one flip are still
50 percent.
But if in advance I say to you, what are the
odds of heads twice in a row?
You multiply point five times, point five,
and you get 25 percent.
Similarly, if Trump's odds really were twenty
nine percent in 2016 and they're 29 percent
now in the abstract, the odds of winning twice
with 29 percent odds are about eight percent.
But it doesn't matter.
It's 29 percent right now.
It's essentially a coin flip from the standpoint
of how we should behave.
Just vote.
Guys, that's it.
And this reinforces, you know, when you see
Biden plus twelve, you might get the impression
that we should be thinking about this differently.
It's 50/50.
This is a critical moment.
This is not a rehearsal.
Let's not mess this up.
There's something very interesting going on
with Noam Chomsky.
Now, Chomsky's in his 90s and Noam Chomsky
has for a long time been a progressive hero
to many on the left.
Until recently, when he started saying things
that sound, to be quite frank, more like me,
I'm often called a neo liberal shill by some
on the left who think I'm just not quite progressive
enough in Noam Chomsky suffering a lot of
the same fate right now.
Recently, Noam Chomsky said it's so important
to remove Trump that every Bernie supporters
should vote for Biden.
I agree with that.
Noam Chomsky now agrees.
A lot of people in a suit in a sliver of my
audience were very mad about Noam Chomsky
saying that Chomsky was recently interviewed
by a non Gary Dhara Das, who's been a guest
on the show.
And Chomsky again said things that sound a
lot like me.
And some people on the left are now furious
with Chomsky.
Now, one of the things I've been saying is
that as a presidential nominee for a major
party and as a possible president, Joe Biden
is running to the left of just about every
candidate candidacy I can think of in the
modern political era.
Biden is to Obama's left on climate and on
health care and on financial policy.
And it makes sense because it's 12 years later
the country and the Democratic Party have
moved to the left.
So it would follow that Biden is to the left
of Hillary and to the left of Obama, and his
campaign indeed is.
And I took a bunch of heat from my viewers
for saying that some people writing in and
saying, David, that's meaningless to say Biden
is the furthest left because Biden might not
be sincere in those policy ideas and he might
not actually get it done.
That applies to any candidate.
That's an impossible criticism to address
because you can apply it to any candidate.
Well, now, Noam Chomsky has said almost the
same thing, who said to a non degree dhara
das quote, take Biden's campaign positions
farther to the left than any Democratic candidate
in memory on things like climate.
It's far better than anything that preceded
it, not because Biden had a personal conversion
or the DNC had some great insight, but because
they're being hammered on by activists coming
out of the Sanders movement and others.
The climate program, a two trillion dollar
commitment to dealing with the extreme threat
of environmental catastrophe was lost, largely
written by the Sunrise movement and strongly
endorsed by the leading activists on climate
change.
The ones who managed to get the green New
Deal on the legislative agenda.
That's real politics.
This is a true, pragmatic sort of realpolitik
from Noam Chomsky, and it actually gets even
more pragmatic.
And it's fascinating to see Chomsky and I
suddenly exactly on the same page on this
issue.
This next quote is from the debate over whether
Biden is good or merely less bad than Trump
and.
We should be thinking about that, and Anon's
says to Chomsky, this is interesting coming
from you, your support for Biden is more than
merely grudging.
You actually seem to think that the platform
is surprisingly good, given who he is and
given where we are.
And Chomsky responds, quote, This is not support
for Biden.
It is support for the activists who have been
at work constantly creating the background
within the party in which the shifts took
place and who have followed Sanders in actually
entering the campaign and influencing its
support for them, support for real politics.
The left position is you rarely support anyone.
You vote against the worst.
You keep the pressure and the activism going.
Chomsky is pointing out it's not new, that
the left is in a position of supporting the
least bad.
It's common that the left is choosing between
options that are not ideal or perfect or great,
and that that's how progress works.
And yet, on the one hand.
Sure.
Systemic change has to come in order to really
improve society.
I'm with you.
But another four years of Trump pushes us
towards this bizarre neo fascism that Donald
Trump has espoused even more at.
And and it gives us another four years of
falling behind on climate and on so many issues
and things will get worse.
Now, some people will say it's the Biden types,
one after another.
You know, Obama, the Hillary candidacy now
Biden.
That's what led to Trump in some fundamental
sense.
Everything that happened before today led
to where we are today.
The outcomes are a result of everything that
has happened.
But it is ridiculous to say it's only because
of the Democratic nominees that we now have
Trump.
That's a silly argument.
It's indefensible.
We also got Trump because of anti intellectual
ism, xenophobia, racism, Obama being half
black.
You know that there's this very long list
of factors and there is no evidence that another
four years of Trump in power will generate
the collapse that some on the left want to
see because they believe it will usher in
some truly left system of government.
There's no evidence that that would happen.
The last four years have proven that.
And it's very interesting to hear this not
from me, although this sounds like my monologues
from four months ago, but from Noam Chomsky.
We'll have continued coverage of this on the
David Pakman show.
Instagram David Pakman show.
And you can follow me on Instagram as well
at David Dot.